INHERITED A ECONOMY DURING THE
GREAT DEPRESSION LOSING HOMES
AND HOPE.
>> ONE WAY TO DEAL WITH THE
IMPACT OF A FAMILY THAN WHAT WE
ARE DOING AND WE ARE GOING TO
BEAT INFLATION.
>> IT IS REALLY THE NUMBER ONE
ECONOMIC ISSUE THAT FACE THE
DURATION AND THE NATION.
>> WHAT ACTIONS ARE YOU TAKING
TO RELIEVE THE PAIN OF FAMILIES
WE HAVE TO ASK THEM WHAT ARE YOU
DOING?
WHAT DONE DOES IT MEAN?
>> LET'S BRING IN HUGH HEWITT,
KIMBERLEY STRASSEL AT THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" AND JEFF MASON
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT FOR
REUTERS.
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU.
JUST TODAY I WENT UP TO GALLOP
POLLING TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S THE
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE FACING THE
COUNTRY.
AND KIM, NOT SURPRISING TODAY,
35% OF THE RESPONDENT DENTS HAD
THE ECONOMY AT THE TOP OF THEIR
LIST, THE ADMINISTRATION IS
SCRAMBLING ON THIS NO MATTER
WHAT THEY TRY IT SEEMS AT THIS
POINT.
O.
>> THE DEMOCRATS SPENT THE LAST
WEEK TALKING ENDLESSLY ABOUT
ABORTION.
CLEARLY HOPING TO CHANGE FOCUS
AND GET AMERICANS' MINDS ON
SOMETHING ELSE.
BUT THOSE POLLS SHOW THAT THIS
IS A PERVASIVE PROBLEM NOW FOR
THEM.
WHAT'S EVEN MORE WORRISOME IS IF
YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS THIS
WEEK, WHETHER A IT REALLY
SUGGESTS IS THAT WE HAVE GOT
SOARING DEMAND TOO FEW WORKERS
AND NOW WHAT IS CALLED A WAGE
PRICE CYCLE WHERE COMPANIES HAVE
TO SPEND MORE TO GET WORKERS TO
STAY ON OR ABOUT COME ON.
THEY THEN HIKE THEIR PRICES THEN
WORKERS DEMAND HIGHER WAGES AND
UP WE GO THE WHITE HOUSE IS
GOING TO STRUGGLE TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS AND ADD IN MOSTLY
WHAT IT IS DOING IT IS CUTTING
BACK YOU ENERGY SUPPLIES AND
ADDING REGULATIONS TO MAKE
COMPANIES PULL BACK.
THAT IS THE EXACT OPPOSITE WHAT
YOU NEED TO BE DOING TO HELP
YOURSELF POLITICALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY.
>> SO TO THE POINT OF ENERGY
SUPPLIES PLAY A LITTLE BACK AND
FORTH SECRETARY YELLEN AND GETS
TO DOMESTIC PRODUCTION.
>> DID CONSIDER THE SUBSTANTIAL
RISK THAT IS ACTUALLY NOW
MATERIALIZED THAT OVERREGULATION
OF THE FOSSIL ENERGY SECTOR
ENDING KEYSTONE BLOCKING ON
FEDERAL LANDS.
CON STRANGE SUPPLY OF ENERGY HAS
ACTUALLY UNDERMINED STABILITY
HISTORIC INFLATION AND $4.37 A
GALLON GAS?
>> I THINK WE OWE THAT TO THE
FAILURE OF OUR DOMESTIC INDUSTRY
TO RAMP UP PRODUCTION TO.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S WHAT
THEY SAY.
I THINK THEY SAY THEY CAN'T GET
APPROVAL.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF BACK AND
FORTH ON.
THAT WAS THERE IS THE WHITE
HOUSE CALLING OUT THE OIL
COMPANIES AS BAD GUYS AS PEOPLE
ARE PROFITING OFF OF, YOU KNOW,
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND SAYING THAT THEY AREN'T
USING DOMESTIC PRODUCTION.
THEY ARE SAYING THIS ISN'T
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS
OVERNIGHT.
WE CAN'T GET APPROVAL FOR SOME
OF THESE PROJECTS AND THERE ARE
MAJOR INVESTMENTS INVOLVED.
WHERE DO YOU COME DOWN ON THIS.
>> I COME DOWN TO SECRETARY
YELLEN ACTUALLY MADE ME DRAW
BACK AND WONDER WHEN SHE SAID
THE PRODUCTION COMPANIES ARE NOT
WILLING TO PRODUCE.
THIS VERY DAY THE ADMINISTRATION
CANCELED OIL AND GAS LEASES IN
ALASKA.
LAST WEEK THEY WITHDREW THEM IN
THE GULF OF MEXICO.
OF COURSE WE CAN GO BACK TO
KEYSTONE.
THIS IS AN ANTI ENERGY
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THAT, OF COURSE, HAS
KIMBERLY JUST SAID, INCREASES
PRESSURE.
ENERGY MARKETS ARE
FORWARD-LOOKING AND SO LONG AS
THEY SEE AHEAD OF THEM OBSTACLES
FROM EVERY DEPARTMENT REGULATORY
IMPEDIMENTS FROM EVERY OFFICIAL
WITH A PEN AND A BUREAUCRATIC
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO PRODUCE.
I JUST CAN'T ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THAT JANET YELLEN SAID ITS THE
PRODUCERS' FAULT WHEN JOE BIDEN
IS THROWING EVERY OBSTACLE IN
THE WAY HE CAN.
>> IT'S NOT JUST CONSERVATIVES
THAT HAVE CRITIQUES.
NOT A RIGHT LEANING PUBLICATION
SAYS THIS.
FOR MUCH OF THE LAST YEAR THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WRONGLY
TOLD THE AMERICAN PUBLIC THAT
RISING PRICES WOULD BE SHORT
LIVED.
WHEN IT BECAME CLEAR THAT
INFLATION INTO THE COME DOWN ON
ITS OWN, THE WHITE HOUSE BEGAN A
BLAME GAME ONE OF ITS FAVORITE
TALKING POINTS PIN INFLATION ON
GREEDY CORPORATIONS FOR HIKING
PRICES TOO MUCH.
THAT JUST DOESN'T ADD UP.
THAT IS FROM THE EDITORIAL
BOARD, JEFF.
>> THEY ARE CITING THE IMPACT OF
THE WAR IN UKRAINE AND THE
ONGOING IMPACT OF THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC, BUT "THE WASHINGTON
POST" CERTAINLY RIGHT THE
ADMINISTRATION LAST YEAR SAID
INFLATION WOULD BE TRANSITORY IT
DID NOT TURN OUT TO BE THAT WAY.
I ASKED PRESIDENT BIDEN A
QUESTION ABOUT THAT EARLIER THIS
WEEK AFTER HIS SPEECH ABOUT
INFLATION.
I SAID, YOU INITIALLY THOUGHT
THIS WAS GOING TO BE TRANSITORY.
THAT NOT THE CASE CHALLENGE.
IS YOUR PROJECTION NOW?
HE DIDN'T WANT TO GIVE A
PROJECTION.
THAT'S PROBABLY BECAUSE THEY
JUST DON'T KNOW.
THEY WANT IT TO COME DOWN
OBVIOUSLY.
IT IS NOT ONLY AN ECONOMIC
LIABILITY FOR THIS PRESIDENT.
ALSO A POLITICAL LIABILITY GOING
INTO THE NOVEMBER MIDTERMS.
>> LET'S TALK COVID.
THE WHITE HOUSE WAS PART OF THIS
GLOBAL CONVERSATION TODAY.
HERE IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE THERE IS
STILL SO MUCH TO DO.
THIS PANDEMIC ISN'T OVER.
THOUSANDS STILL DYING EVERY DAY.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR US TO ACT.
ALL OF US TOGETHER.
WE MUST DO MORE.
>> WE HAVE CALLED UPON THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS FOR
$22.5 BILLION IN ADDITIONAL
EMERGENCY FUNDING TO BATTLE
COVID.
>> Shannon: OKAY.
LET ME PUT UP ANOTHER NUMBER
ASKING FOR FUNDING AND SAYING
THIS IS NOT OVER YET THE PEOPLE
WORRIED ABOUT COVID AND OUR
SITUATION, THESE NUMBERS HAVE
STEADILY DROPPED.
PEOPLE WORRIED ABOUT GETTING
COVID BACK IN APRIL OF 2020 WERE
69%.
WE'RE NOW AT 17%.
SO, HUGH, HOW DO YOU CONVINCE
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN THAT WE
NEED BILLIONS MORE DOLLARS FOR
SOMETHING THAT THEY SEEM LIKE
THEY MAY BE COMING TO TERMS PART
OF DAILY LIFE.
>> IT CANNOT BE DONE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T
BELIEVE IT THOSE WHO WANT TO BE
VACCINATED AND BOOSTED ARE
VACCINATED AND BOOSTED.
THEY ARE LIVING THEIR ORDINARY
LICE.
ADD CLICHES TO THE BOOSTERS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO TURN THE PAGE
TO THE ECONOMY OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE OVER
COVID AND THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
GO BACK TO COVID.
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION KNOWS
THAT BUT THEY HAVE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING WITH THE PRESIDENT
THAT DOESN'T LET HIM WANDER
AROUND A MICROPHONE IN HAND IN
AN AUDIENCE MAKING GAFFES.
>> Shannon: KIM, IT IS ONE OF
THE FEW TOPICS THAT IN ALL OF
THE POLLING HE IS NOT UPSIDE
DOWN.
IS HE ON IMMIGRATION, THE
BORDER, RUSSIA, THE ECONOMY.
BUT HE IS STARTING TO MAKE GAINS
ON COVID.
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
GAINING CONFIDENCE IN HIS
ABILITY TO HANDLE THIS.
>> WELL, THAT SEEMS TO BE MOSTLY
A FUNCTION THOUGH OF THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE NOT CARING ABOUT
IT AS MUCH.
>> Shannon: MAYBE.
>> WHICH IS YOUR POINT.
THAT SEEMS TO BE THE MAIN POINT
OF THIS.
NOW, LOOK, I THINK ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
HERE IS THAT TO THE EXTENT IT
FOCUSES ON COVID, IT DOES IT IN
A WAY THAT TENDS TO REALLY ANNOY
A LOT OF AMERICANS.
AND THAT IT'S ALL FOCUSED ON
MASK MANDATES, ON AIRPLANES.
OTHER THINGS ARE DESIGNED TO
LOCK PEOPLE UP, TAKE AWAY THEIR
FREEDOMS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT POLLING,
WHAT IT SHOWS HERE IS AMERICANS
NOW WANT TO LIVE WITH COVID, AND
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION WAS
SMART IT WOULD BE CONTINUING ITS
EFFORTS BUT ON THINGS THAT HAVE
MORE TO DO WITH THERAPEUTICS,
FOR INSTANCE, TESTS AND OTHER
THINGS THAT ALLOW AMERICANS TO
MANAGE THEIR DAY-TO-DAY LIVES
WITH THE PANDEMIC ALONGSIDE OF
IT RATHER THAN A DISRUPTION ON A
DAY-TO-DAY BASIS:
>> Shannon: I WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE GET TO THE SUPREME COURT AND
EFFORTS TO GET ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS FOR THEM.
HERE IS A BREAKDOWN OF REACTION
TO WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
>> THE GARLAND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS NOWHERE IN SIGHT.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS QUICKER
TO POUNCE ON CONCERNED PARENTS
AT SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS.
>> THEY PUT BARRIERS UP IN ORDER
TO PROTECT THE SUPREME COURT
BUILDING.
THIS IS WHAT WE SHOULD DO AROUND
THE JUSTICES' HOMES.
I THINK WE CAN BOTH RESPECT
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS AND
PROTECT THE SANCTITY OF OUR
JUSTICES' HOME.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN YOU NEED TO
TELL YOUR ATTORNEY GENERAL TO GO
AND DO HIS JOB AND PROTECT THE
CITIZENS OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
ULTIMATELY, SIR, THIS FALLS ON
YOU.
OF.
>> Shannon: THERE IS A FEDERAL
LAW THAT APPEARS TO BE PRETTY
CLEAR WHAT HAPPENS THE FACT IT'S
AGAINST THE LAW TO PICKET OR
PARADE IN FRONT OF A JURIST'S
HOME TO INFLUENCE THEIR DECISION
AS WE AWAIT THE ACTUAL OFFICIAL
OPINION FROM THE SUPREME COURT.
THE DOJ IT S. TAKING A LOT OF
THE HEAT FOR BEING TO STEP IN ON
A NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS BUT NOT
NECESSARILY THIS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF WHAT THEY
HAVE SAID SO FAR?
>> I THINK THIS JUST REPRESENTS
THE FACT THIS IS SUCH A DIVISIVE
ISSUE AND IT'S FOCUSED RIGHT NOW
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE IS FOCUSED
ON THESE PROTESTS, THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE IS FOCUSED ON
WHAT THAT DECISION IS LIKELY
GOING TO BE BASED ON THE LEAKED
DRAFTED.
IT'S DIVISIVE.
AND THERE IS GOING TO BE
PRESSURE ON BOTH SIDES.
SHANNON, IF I CAN ALSO TAKE ONE
SECOND TO GO BACK TO THE
PREVIOUS DISCUSSION ABOUT COVID,
TO KIM'S POINT, THE
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING THAT
WHICH HE SAID THEY SHOULD BE
DOING THAT'S WHY THEY ARE ASKING
FOR MONEY.
THE ASK MAY BE CONTROVERSIAL
BECAUSE IT'S A BIG NUMBER.
BUT THEY ARE ASKING FOR BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS SO THAT AMERICANS CAN
HAVE VACCINES, CAN HAVE TESTS
AND CAN HAVE CHIEWRPDZ THIS
FALL.
>> Shannon: WE